[Music]
food i love eating it talking about it
watching it on tv here is some delicious
kitchen inspiration
hey drew it's leo aka chili tumble king
and i'm here to show you how to make my
favorite smoothie bowl the drew berry
marble
first add one cup of frozen fruit to
your blender second add two slightly
thought acai packets to the blender oh
it's looking good third add a quarter
cup of any milk you choose
then blend on high until it's super
duper smooth
now that you've blended the base pour in
a bowl and smooth out the top oh that
looks good now it's time to garnish you
can use almost anything to garnish
granola hazelnut spread or maybe even
fruits but since this is the drew
barrymore bowl i'm gonna use some of her
favorite color yellow to add some banana
and some other things and then obviously
some berries for the drew barry marshall
look at the final product it could be in
the museum and it tastes great too this
is guaranteed to make your afternoon way
better mwah
hi drew this is archana from ministry of
curry and i'm going to show you how to
make delicious butter chicken in the
instant pot set instant pot to saute
more and heat two tablespoons of ghee
and a cup of diced onion two teaspoons
of salt saute this for two to three
minutes add a tablespoon each of ginger
and garlic half a teaspoon of turmeric
two teaspoons of red chili powder 1
teaspoon of garam masala half a cup of
water and a cup of tomato puree add 2
pounds of chicken thighs and give a good
stir pressure cook this for 8 minutes
stir in half a cup of cream
two tablespoons of tomato paste and a
teaspoon of sugar two tablespoons of dry
fenugreek leaves
cook on saute more as you get a nice
thick creamy curry enjoy
okay so i don't make dessert often so
you want to trust me when i say this
dulce de leche lava cake was epic first
you're going to crack an egg and an egg
yolk add your sugar and you're going to
beat it until it looks like that
you're going to add your crusade letter
to a bowl with your butter melted bean
marine
and add it to the eggs with your flour
cinnamon
and grease your ramekin with butter add
a little sugar so it doesn't stick bake
them up then we're going to make our
little drizzle cream run the knife
through it so it comes off smooth
add your ice cream your drizzle and
you're done hi drew i'm alice from hip
footy mom and today we're gonna make my
sweet potato deviled eggs just like any
regular deviled eggs recipe you want to
start with hard-boiled eggs
my tip for making hard-boiled eggs that
are really easy to peel use your
pressure cooker immediately put them
into an ice bath and then i like to peel
them under running water i feel like
that helps once you have your eggs
cooked and ready to go we are ready to
pulse them up in a food processor into
my food processor i am gonna add my
cooked egg yolks
one cooked sweet potato i have some
white cheddar cheese some hot sauce sour
cream dijon mustard and we're going to
season with some salt and pepper and now
we're going to pulse this up until
smooth
[Music]
and now i'm going to put all this into a
piping bag so we can pipe it into our
eggs
now we're going to garnish with some
crispy bacon bits and some chives and
here's our finished platter of deviled
eggs this to me is what cooking is all
about putting your own spin on recipes
and just having fun in the kitchen drew
thank you so much for having me i had so
much fun
wow i'm in a delicious food coma just
for watching that
[Music]